here is a black lesbian wanda sykes
here's black lesbian comedian wanda
sykes on the stephen colbert
comedy program last night and she has
just had it with all you people how are
you doing how are you doing i'm a black
gay woman and i have a daughter so i'm
not doing so well right now
i'm a little salty
you're a little salty i'm a little salty
right now okay yeah yeah we'll sprinkle
a little salt yeah
let's put some flavor on here sucks man
it it really does i mean you know it's
like the
the country it's no longer a democracy
right i mean we're it's no longer
majority rule
no certainly not the senate certainly
yeah the representation of the stream
before it's not it's not it's no longer
majority rule and and i mean it's like
the these judges that just
they basically lied when they were you
know being during their confirmation
hearings right yeah
especially kavanaugh
yeah
so how you how can you be a supreme
court justice and you just you're just
lying you know what they had their
fingers crossed or something or what i
mean
it's yeah it's just it's just a bunch of
horses it really is
[Applause]
well to me it's like the problem is that
middle stuff
is it's those states in the middle that
that that red stuff
why they get to tell us what to do when
the majority of us live
out you know new york california and
we're paying for all this crap really i
mean right
we're putting the bill
well that's that's the union it's
supposed to be representative democracy
but it turns out to be minority rule
right now right right but if we fit in
the bill
you know
and and and like california if it will a
country be what
like the fifth largest fourth fifth
largest economy so if you know if i'm
fitting the bill know your position you
know what i'm saying
you know for real like look if i say hey
let's go out to dinner you don't get to
pick the restaurant just shut up and eat
there's so much stupidity there that i
actually almost have to apologize for
playing it it's so stupid first off she
is a black gay woman and she's salty
there's something funny about that
um nobody cares nobody's coming for her
you're a black gay woman and you're a
mother zippity doodah lady nobody cares
nobody's coming for you
you did your thing you're a millionaire
you're doing quite well in america it's
all good she's very upset that the
majority uh can't rule over the minority
which uh i thought we were supposed to
care about minority rights i thought we
were supposed to look out for the other
guy but she seems to want you know if
everyone says you're supposed to do
something you're supposed to do it
the two of these wizards also have no
sense of what federalism is we've talked
quite a bit about federalism and i want
to thank phoenix today my associate
producer who brought in his copy of the
federalist papers i do have a copy of
the federalist papers here but we're
still not even fully unpacked so phoenix
brought in his copy
and let me tell you a little bit about
federalism in case i haven't made it
clear here conor threw it up on the
screen there federalism mode of
political organization that unites
separate states or other polites within
the overreaching political system in a
way that allows each to maintain its own
integrity federal systems do this by
requiring that basic policies be made
and implemented through negotiation in
some form so that all the members can
share in the making and executing of the
decisions the political principles that
animate federal systems emphasize the
primacy of bargaining and negotiated
coordination among several power centers
they stress the virtues of dispersed
power centers as a means for
safeguarding individual and local
liberties
the various political systems that call
themselves federal differ in many ways
certain characteristics and principles
however are common to all truly federal
systems so yes this is a beautiful thing
if you believe in individual choice if
you are
pro-choice pro-humans having some
capacity to make decisions for
themselves and live in places that are
more in line with their values and all
of those things then that is happening
right now but we have a black lesbian
mother who is very upset even though
nobody is coming to get her